let's put our hands together for 10 15
all right so if I could have you guys
all look under your chairs tell me if
you have a purple post-it note I think
you're gonna find that most of you do
not only about thirty percent of you
have a post-it note the reason for that
is because thirty percent is about the
number of the percentage of students
that are engaged in classrooms today and
it's also the percentage of teachers
that find meaningful time to do
collaboration now me I was a product of
No Child Left Behind I was asked to
memorize information I was asked to take
multiple choice tests and now that I'm a
first year teacher I rely on that how I
was taught to inform my students and so
I asked what resources do I have in
order to make my curriculum when I'm
expected to do common core and make it
more engaging I have to basically one my
textbook which is still NCLB structured
which still has multiple choice which is
still not very real-world applied and I
have my fellow teachers who have also
been teaching NCLB for many years and we
don't have enough time to collaborate so
what options do I have alright so for
teachers like will we amended open box
so open boxes as a platform that
involves communities of teachers of
students with parents administrators
college students and businesses they
they brainstorm real life real world
relevant challenges that teachers and
students can then go into the classroom
and solve so here's how it works well
can go online make a profile specify
some things about his class like the
grade the subject the concept robbery so
he can either choose a lucky choose
choose one for us to surprise him with
and so if he dies on the big day he
opens it with his class and tada it's a
surprise it's a real world relevant
challenge for will for his students to
solve and so um open box is there are no
right or wrong answers it's about fun
it's about engagement it's about
learning and so at the end students are
tasked with the toss to reteach this to
their teachers and then they go back
with feedback with advice and this
collaboration is key
we starting to pay for all of this who's
going to pay for all of this is like I
think about us a red box or a netflix
subscription you get the box you've
already paid for it when you return it
you actually get some money refunded
back or if you return the results of the
project you get it back so this is a
for-profit funded model by the consumer
and so those we don't have the ability
to do it communities we challenges
they're not inside this project bringing
foundation support absolutely really
fast about a reflective model as well so
if you understand didn't have the
mastery of whatever it is that they've
learned and they can teach it back to
the instructor that is the highest level
if you will of teaching and that's what
we're hoping now we're kind of like
challenging that and now bringing it
back the students teach us the teachers
one of the challenge is sort of like a
birch box like yeah either consume their
back in the box what was it um there was
a calm in the box basically I was time
about a time I travel to Rwanda there's
a big problem with like maintaining
water and like not having to travel far
so there's a problem statement in that
it says you know here's some materials
construct something that is able to make
the water transportable that you can
travel with it that you can easily you
know access it so that you don't have to
be you know traveling twice a week with
your class to get water or you know
cetera so we just put whatever was in
the what was accessible to us in the
design job so obviously we would maybe
pre pre think a little more what we
would give the students but you know we
sort of leave it up to them to be
creative and see what they come up with
there's no real right or wrong answer
but the beauty is that it Maps back to
standards you can actually use in the
real world so this is a real model that
you can use comes to you in a box and
the teacher is on the same side as the
students because we're all trying to
problem solve together it democratizes
the classroom right and more importantly
I think this collaborative this notion
of collaboration so we'll is one I think
everybody in this room is 1 and wants to
build so we want to harvest that and you
know build it organically from the
bottom up you know to make sure to make
a mistake I'll do correct it you have
the wrong box content to this person
house you correct this I mean really
being flexible like that's something
that
you need that's a skill you need to have
in the real business world I'm kind of
using what you have be creative make
solutions